le dernier crash d'un avion militaire en
franche-comté concerne un appareil
suisse un f-18 s'est écrasé en octobre
2015 sur la commune de glam monde en a
une vingtaine de kilomètres de besançon
le pilote avait réussi à s'éjecter en
juin 2013 c'est cette fois un militaire
français qui activent son siège
éjectable
avant que son mirage 2000 ne s'écrase
sur la commune de mon cours en haute
saône
le pilote rentrait de mission et
rejoignez la base aérienne de luxeuil
les bains en octobre 2012
un autre appareil de la baie à 116
s'écrase à froideconche quelques minutes
seulement après son décollage le pilote
de nationalité taïwanaise n'a pas
survécu à cet accident
en 1971 un autre pilote de la baie à 116
avait perdu la vie dans le crash de son
appareil sur le secteur de vranes dans
le haut doubs à quelques kilomètres
seulement de l'accident de ce mercredi